this right here is a little pendulum
simulation that i created on the khan
academy computer science section or on
our code scratch pad and the purpose of
it is for it to really be a virtual
laboratory for you to kind of get
intuition for what affects the pendulum
how does a pendulum change depending on
different parameters so right now it's
just motionless but we can if i click on
it i can change the length of the string
or i can change the initial angle you
see that they're changing in the top
left corner so right now my initial
angle is 30 degrees and my strength
length is 8.5 meters the mass of what
you see that that little uh bunny
looking thing with the
on this spaceship that's we're assuming
10 kilograms and the gravitational field
is 9 the strength of the gravitational
field is 9.8 meters per second squared
which is roughly what it is at the
surface of earth and so when i let go of
the pendulum so i just unclicked right
there you see the pendulum swinging back
and forth and the current implementation
of it assumes that there is no air so
there's no air resistance or no energy
loss to the friction with the air or
even with the friction of the pendulum
itself where it pivots or anything like
that so one thing i encourage you to do
with first is just play with the
pendulum and get a feel for how it moves
see what happens when maybe you have a
shorter string see what happens when you
have a longer string when you have a
bigger angle or a smaller angle but
that's not the only thing that you can
change you can also change the mass of
the object so you see one it gets a
little bit bigger but also you see this
mass number changing based on where you
move this little this little
magenta-haired individual and you can
also change the gravitational field to
see how would this pendulum operate if
it were on a different planet maybe and
so if we change this we click on the
star this little small star we can
change the strength of the actual
gravitational field so the first thing
that i think is interesting is just to
play around with this a lot and get a
sense for the pendulum and then i want
you to start thinking about how these
different things the gravitational field
the length of the string the mass the
initial angle how this affects the
period of the pendulum and just to be
clear what a period of a pendulum is
it's how long does it take for the
pendulum to go from one spot or one
state to that same state again so here
from there
let's say you start there so from that
moment all the way back to this moment
how much time has passed and you see
here that the tool actually measures it
for you is about 5.1 or 5.2 seconds and
it's very important it's from the exact
same state so if you're if you want to
measure from the bottom you have to
measure when it's going in the same
direction so it could be from
now
not until now but until now when it was
going backwards again and so it's going
to take it a little while we changed we
changed the initial angle a little bit
and so we got a slightly different
period
this predicted zero seconds that is
wrong and that's wrong because
the whole point of this is for you to
explore what would how can you predict
what the period is based on things like
the initial angle based on the string
length based on the mass so one thing i
want to do is just play with this as
much as you can change the mass change
the gravitational field and try to get a
sense and you might want to do one at a
time so for example you might only want
to change the string length first and
say well how does that how does if i
have the same initial angle let's say i
always have a 20 degree angle
how does and i change the string length
how does that change the period and then
hold everything constant and see how the
gravity changes it and you might want to
even plot it on paper and see if you can
get a sense of what the mathematical
relationship might be and once you get a
really good sense of that and you really
want to take it to the next level you
can even play with mass see how that
might affect the period and once you do
all of that and you have you start to
have a pretty good intuition of things
the next step is to try to come up with
a formula try to implement this
predicted period function and if you
want to go in the code it's right over
here so this is what i did not implement
you see i just set p equals zero that's
why it just says zero seconds right over
there but you might wanna set up some
code or put up some formulas or do some
computation here to better predict the
actual period and i encourage you to do
any research you might have to do
research on the web try to implement
things that you find there and see how
good they actually do approximate the
actual period and it would be fun to see
if you can get even more accurate than
anything that you even find on the web
any of those formulas or anything like
that but the key thing is to really try
to understand and that first step why
any of these formulas actually make
intuitive sense why they actually
feel or why they they might look the way
you do they do and if you want to really
understand all the code or maybe even
try to kind of branch off and do a save
as and make your own version of this
code i encourage you to press play right
over here that's an explanation where
i'm actually explaining the actual code
and from there you can take this
wherever you want you can add more bells
and whistles to this simulation or you
could even turn this into some type of a
game